vamos a hablar de la crisis alimentaria
que según varias organizaciones
humanitarias sería generada por la
emergencia climática como ya lo veníamos
hablando con ross aparece la revista de
prensa más de 12 millones de muertes en
todo el mundo están asociadas a factores
de riesgo ambiental cada año según el
subdirector de la organización
panamericana de la salud jarbas barbosa
esto de cara a la cumbre a la cumbre
climática con 26 que comienza este
domingo en glasgow y el programa también
de naciones unidas para el medio
ambiente informó que si bien los países
han prometido reducir las emisiones de
estos gases de efecto invernadero
todavía existe una gran brecha entre
esas promesas y lo que se necesita para
realmente evitar las peores
consecuencias de esta crisis climática
para ello quiero entonces saludar a
nuestro primer invitado al día el es el
cargo carlos aguilar responsable
regional de justicia climática para
américa latina de oxfam carlos gracias
por estar aquí con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 me gusta no ese
nombre que le han puesto a este esta
oficina justicia climática le quiero
preguntar si es cierto entonces que el
cambio climático está generando esta
crisis alimentaria todo el mundo
muchas gracias raúl miren creo que es
muy importante entender que estamos en
medio de una crisis climática en este
momento a nivel global los efectos de
esta crisis son diferenciados están
relacionados con las políticas que se
aplican a nivel local oa nivel nacional
pero también por referencia a los
problemas de desigualdad y pobreza que
se vive en los países y esa crisis se
desarrolla en un contexto muy complejo
debido a la crisis pandémica que también
vivimos lo que aporta una enorme presión
sobre los alimentos y sobre los recursos
naturales o recursos estratégicos para
la recuperación económica de nuestros
países carlos hablabas de un punto muy
importante es la disparidad la
desigualdad y es que mire este dato el 2
por ciento de la riqueza del moscú
podría resolver el hambre mundial eso lo
dijo el director del programa para la
escasez de alimentos de la onu
imagínense cómo se puede solucionar esta
disparidad
el tema de la del problema alimentario
como el de la crisis climática debe ser
resuelto con decisiones políticas el
problema es que en muchos sentidos
existe la falta de
interés o incluso de voluntad política
de gobiernos estratégicos para
encaminarse por por los rumbos de
soluciones que se requieren en torno a
esta situación sabemos que el problema
del hambre no es un problema de escasez
de alimentos es un problema de
distribución y obviamente en algunos
países es un problema de acceso a la
tierra en un problema de políticas para
apoyar a los pequeños productores y
campesinos y campesinas y sabemos que
todo esto está relacionado profundamente
con una desigualdad y la pobreza y por
qué no decirlo también con la violencia
que se vive en nuestros países que
exactamente también general desplazan
desplazamiento de estos agricultores
para poder cosechar las tierras y puedes
alimentarse y vender sus productos pero
les quiero volver al tema de la 26 qué
va a pasar en escocia respecto a la
seguridad alimentaria generada por el
cambio climático usted ve que si
realmente se pueden tomar medidas
necesarias y efectivas que se aplican en
nuestros países y en todo el mundo para
resolver este problema o como también lo
decía el primer ministro británico boris
johnson a hacer otra cumbre de puro bla
bla bla también como lo decía greta
greta ton ver la activista climática
bueno las medidas son urgentes y están
todos los documentos informes del panel
de expertos internacionales sobre cambio
climático insistiendo en la necesidad de
que estas medidas se adopten cuanto
antes por los efectos que puedan tener
sobre las poblaciones más vulnerables a
nivel del planeta entonces
nosotros sí estamos trabajando por
presionar a los gobiernos representados
en la con 26 para que ellos adopten
responsablemente las medidas que se
necesitan primero para mantener la
temperatura del planeta no superior al
1.5 grados que sería fatal y rebasar y
amos todos los límites en términos de
temperatura planetaria
y segundo en relación con algunas
medidas de financiamiento climático y
también
relacionadas con el apoyo a las
poblaciones que están sufriendo los
efectos más desastrosos en materia de la
crisis climática carlos que quiere
preguntar entonces cuáles son las
regiones y los alimentos más afectados
en torno a esta crisis climática que ya
se está empezando a afectar
como le decía al inicio los efectos de
esta crisis climática son diferenciados
américa latina es una de las regiones
más afectadas por la crisis climática a
pesar de que es una de las regiones que
menos contribuye en términos de
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
y eso es una disparidad importante de
considerar en el marco las negociaciones
internacionales es muy importante para
nosotros el tema alimentario porque
sabemos que regiones como centroamérica
o el caribe están sufriendo una enorme
presión alrededor del tema del hambre
están sufriendo una enorme presión por
algunos fenómenos climáticos extremos
que están generando incluso migraciones
como te lo mencionaba también al inicio
de esta nota y nos preocupa
particularmente el impacto que eso pueda
tener sobre las mujeres y los jóvenes en
ese sentido queremos remarcar la
importancia de que se preste una
atención especial a estas poblaciones y
que los gobiernos actúen pronto frente
al drama que ya vive en estas
poblaciones en los países de américa
latina carlos estamos en un retroceso en
la lucha contra el hambre mundial a
alcanzar el objetivo de desarrollo
sostenible queda fuera del alcance de
cara al año 2030
no no quiero ser pesimista y quiero
pensar que vamos a seguir luchando y
vamos a seguir esforzándonos por
alcanzar los acuerdos que se requieren
no hay una muy buena noticia es que
muchas de las medidas que se deben
adoptar en materia de adaptación y
resiliencia ya están siendo
desarrolladas en las comunidades en
nuestros países justamente lideradas por
comunidades indígenas comunidades
afrodescendientes
por las mismas mujeres el problema es
que muchas veces estas personas se ven
incluso amenazadas en sus condiciones de
vida y en su vida física por las
políticas y por las medidas que se
adoptan en nuestros países y por eso es
muy importante por ejemplo el marco del
acuerdo de escazú y si no quisiera dejar
de mencionarlo porque es muy importante
todo el tema que tiene que ver con la
información la transparencia y la
proteína participación perdón de la
sociedad civil en las soluciones a este
tema
una última pregunta más que todo
pregunta reflexión carlos alimentos
básicos fuera del alcance de unas tres
mil millones de personas además se
estima que el hambre aguda mata a 11
personas por minuto mientras el kobe de
imagínense mata a 7 personas por minuto
189 millones de personas podrían verse
sumidas en hambruna a corto plazo usted
está de acuerdo con esto sí bueno eso
mismo ha publicado varios informes
importantes sobre el drama del hambre y
estamos alertando sobre esta situación
que se está viviendo la organización de
naciones unidas para la agricultura la
fao también ha venido alertando sobre
esta situación buena parte de los
alimentos que se pierden en en procesos
de comercialización o debido a distintas
dificultades que existen en los países
para que estos alimentos lleguen a la
población que lo requiere y se requiere
voluntad política para resolver esta
problemática se requiere políticas que
se enfoquen en el apoyo
agricultura de baja escala a los ciclos
cortos de producción y comercio a los
mercados campesinos como conocemos en
nuestros países y se requiere poner
atención a las soluciones que están
brindando las comunidades campesinas en
toda américa